i have no dog in this fight i don't want
to be on cnn he can't do anything for me
i can't do anything for him
but jeff zucker powerful guy head of cnn
resigned
because
he's 56
and not married
not that you know that's a personal
thing but okay divorced
was
having a relationship with a 49 year old
i think that's age appropriate so he got
that check for him
also executive at the company and he had
to resign over that i i don't understand
this why a 56 year old and a 49 year old
people can't have a consensual
relationship
i mean they they've been friends for 20
years she said i acknowledge the
the oh he said i acknowledged the
relationship evolved in recent years it
was covent yeah she's boning jeff
because of covington
[Applause]
i would be
totally delighted to never know anything
about the sex life
of cnn c-suite it's in my contract that
i can't know who jeff sucker is
to not know about that and i think you
know we've made it our business we're
sort of busy bodies so we've made it our
business to get into everyone else's
business i will say i am very much team
never cuomo
and so to the extent that
of the mother never almost here to the
extent that uh you know this was a
complicating factor in cnn choosing
not to aggressively and truthfully cover
andrew cuomo by letting chris cuomo do
some of that coverage
you know it's
it's every layer of the onion is just
like dumber and makes you cry more but
if it is true
if it is true that the desire to keep
this affair secret led to cnn dropping
the ball on covering truly a a scandal
in american government then okay let's
look into it but i'm not worried about
what he's doing with his bits my god
it's weird because there are moments
aren't there it's funny as you can tell
i'm an outsider i'm from downton abbey
and there are weird moments when in that
you sort of see the the
puritan history of the united states
come through right americans spend all
their time at work they're going to
each other right this is perfect normal
this is a healthy consensual thing well
we don't anymore but we used to we used
to and we used to go to work and
this is completely different to sexual
harassment actually to be honest it
sounds like quite a touching love story
it does exactly and by the way in the
old days this was called discretion i'm
not going to tell everybody who i'm
now i didn't tell everybody you
aren't it i'm the bad guy
that's a crazy thing
you